i mean i can't say it though i can't say
that the industry wasn't good to me when
you it
you know i just say amen
and i applaud now just remember
specifically obviously at a certain
point in time it felt like you were like
the industry's
next guy everyone was behind you i mean
i remember seeing you you had you had
your own source cover you were you were
very much uh
you know
i remember like the nas main source
moment you know what i mean like we
always did it almost felt like that was
like the closest thing where it was like
yo live at the bar because just kidding
and then you were kind of like the 96 97
version of that right
and
the first album comes out it's i i you
know i thought there was some [ __ ] on
there i like like edward nominatory and
get [ __ ] i mean yeah you know
there's some [ __ ] amazing records on
there but for whatever reason
it felt like you nowadays people get
more than one go i feel like people kind
of that album came and went and like
maybe the beef was like a even though
you won it
might have been a bigger curse than a
you know it was kind of a gift and a
curse hey man it's possible like i i
really i really will tell you that
you know
what
what i was up against i really didn't
know
at that time right and then by the time
i figured it out what i was up against
um
everyone had abandoned ship right i was
pretty much by myself right
um
and
it was something that
i realized what it what it was or what i
thought it was definitely a heavier pill
to swallow than
you know didn't
been being something simple to mitigate
something to figure out and get out of
right but i was in the middle of it so i
couldn't quit i couldn't lay down and i
couldn't just sit there and wait for you
know that that that grindstone that
grinds everything to dust you know what
i mean so i had to keep it pushing and
that's what i did and
um that i'll give you know i give all of
or praise to the creator for me still
being here now because there were dark
times there i'm sure things that went
through and and you know right now
though
even though you know we talk about
you're the industry there's no yeah but
you know what though
like the kaiju the release of this kaiju
record there were records man like you
got melatonin magic you got like for
whom to be told she have a lyrical law
he had to rip the jacker like there were
records that might club the curriculum
there were a lot of records that came
out in time flies there were records
that came out after that
that
i'd say the brotherhood like the fan
base the listeners the rippers like
people that
they don't care what what the game
talking about what the industry talking
about they want to hear what candles got
to say yeah
they came through in the clutch